[Music]
[Applause]
like like this one right here extremely
last-minute Halloween costumes good well
that's a good one wine box hat so last
minute you didn't even cut eyeholes no
no time for I know he's stumbling around
into traffic and there's more here check
this out there's naked secret agent and
then check out this guy next to him it's
yeah check that out sharpie Hitler
sharpie Hitler it takes 30 seconds to be
sharpie Hitler check out this book I
can't believe this didn't sell but it
didn't famous guitarists shredding right
they're shredding away and there you
have mr. BB king I think that's
mozzarella parmesan I can tell ya and
then we've got one of the Great's of all
time mr. Eric Clapton he's shredding up
shredding lettuce lettuce it's a
fascinating book you've got to check it
out its up you're muttering check this
one out I had to have this one it didn't
sell newborns with sides oh yeah that
kid could be like in a baby Metallica
yeah they're so adorable and each one
they just get better
love that kid and then look at this kid
down here fantastic apparently it's a
common condition condition yeah here's a
coffee table book I had to have it's
called guys pretending to listen to you
while staring at your breasts
that's a coffee table book of guys I
know that look well yeah and then over
here we got there's a
see the my let's move on through no
longer to lie there we go there's that
guy yeah and then yeah
[Applause]
I'm the least I'm the least killer do
you think you're a terrible job I'm
making no effort there yeah to not look
at the bull bear I've got to show you
this one I love this one the big book of
mining terms and or Romney son man's
this is this is flag Oh
slag slag Romney all mining terms and or
Romney son names their Stoke right there
that's a good one keep moving along
there's core you got to love core
[Applause]
humph beep oh hey yeah
they call him DT for short I understand
why this book did not sell its tic-tac
ties a book of tic-tac-toe games that
resulted in ties and if you think the
cover is exciting check out the very a
fought it out it was tooth and nail
there in a while check this one out the
big book of unmolested Boy Scouts yeah
it's a book of unmolested Boy Scouts and
they all well there just seems to be one
there's a campfire a campfire of all the
same ones yeah
I think it'd only come up with one
earned his Photoshop badge
all right I saved the best for last
because that's what I do
that's how I do it and that's how it's
done right here ladies and gentlemen
mannequin dick pics
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look at the guy public beach yeah but
crazy I'm gonna hang on to this one for
a long time